this is gonna hurt my stomach I don't
have a 16 year old stomach anymore you
still look 16 though beautiful I mean 18
18 18 right right good morning guys
today we're headed to Huntington Library
we're gonna meet up with the whole JK
news family um that kind of rhymed we're
doing this like jkn photo shoot and this
is the very first time that we're
actually doing a photo shoot like in the
public and stuff we've never done this
but I guess it's to get content for
social media I'm out of breath because
we were rushing to get here
Julia was already texting us like hey
where are you guys and I'm like oh we're
working cuz it's really packed it's a
really really beautiful day like
beautiful sunny day it's 82 degrees
right now
so I'm actually wearing shorts which I
only wear shorts and I'm on vacation I'm
realized I don't wear shorts when I'm in
Italy I don't know why you are so
color-coordinated other than your skin
being Brown matching all the brown
secure wearing you have red top blue
hair your sandals are blue oh yeah you
didn't like my toenails let's shoot you
away no good morning oh you use a color
fools
[Music]
never come back like we have memberships
this place we love this place we used to
come here all the time and then we just
kind of said our membership back in
February and before February this is the
first time that we doing it we don't
come it's not like the best like
anything that's like touching skin skin
like we're armpits like my thighs
everything they start sweating walk like
this and I feel this one oh you're like
a black sweater in a car okay it tracks
all the heat you know it actually cools
you down black clothes
yeah they recommend that you wear black
clothes in the Sun because if you are
white you're actually like burning
yourself even more because you're
attracting the light black actually
protects you from the Sun really yeah I
don't know is it the way I learned it
was black absorbs the heat and then we
had this conversation we were in Morocco
do you remember everyone wearing their
full on like it's all black no one wears
like true why do I do
reflective boards in film production
bounce light meaning they bounce off
stuff right yeah so then it's bouncing
off right yeah cuz if you have a white
plastic bag and you put something in it
and they have a black plastic bag you
put something in it I bet you anything
the white whatever is inside the white
bag would be more cooked than the black
one perhaps
so you can type a level path because I
googled up the mouse shut the mouth
pretty much we've been here for 10
minutes that's already complained about
her shoulders burning bro you're
allergic to Sun I just made fun of her
son yes how insensitive you are I had no
idea I actually open to bring an
umbrella and I forgot it anyone else I
did that's hurtful
I made fun of other people with Sun our
oranges everyone attack him attack
come get me mad what you're such a pro
at it every time we do it thank you but
I always let me do with my hand it's
exact said that's perfect right there
new china model
[Music]
that nice morning that we're talking
about earlier has turned into a baking
hot tell Friday afternoon yes second
location will be a lot more less
punishing at least doors that we're
gonna go to a restaurant and actually
alright so after the headington we went
to go have lunch with everyone and man
that's restaurants I'm telling him about
the restaurant we just eat at oh my
goodness was like really bad and not
just the kitchen was bad but the
waitress was really really not that good
at her job and it was a ridiculous it
took us two hours yeah a whole two hours
for the moment we sat down Samoan we
left Joe got the worst ordeal you
ordered a burger any burgers or burgers
fast food fastest thing to come out
usually and it didn't even come out he
had to get it to go yeah so Steve
ordered a salad he was the besides Joe
Steve was the last person to get there
their meal the hot food came out first
and the easier food the cold food came
out last so you didn't have dressing on
a salad yeah it got so bad that Stephen
Nikki they were supposed to be filming a
podcast and they were like the words we
can't do this we're just so fuming upset
that we can't even get in the mind and
the creative space yeah they even do the
photos yeah where's your chick photos we
have we got cheese we're supposed to
take photos at the restaurant with the
food but then the food took forever to
come out and then no one even got their
food like all of us at the same time I
was just like certain people were after
food and other people were waiting it
was just it was a mess it was a hot hot
mess but anyway everyone went their
separate ways
and that's when we decided to
supercharge the car
sorry now we just finished the
supercharger that we're at right now is
in
and I grew up in Downey so I was
thinking like hey it would be really
cool to take you guys to my old stomping
grounds and show you the mall that I
grew up in so it's called Stonewood
which is right around here and we're
gonna go check out stone wood before we
head to stone wood add a little bright
and downy there are two Tesla
superchargers there are less than five
minutes away from each other
- and in the area that we live in the
closest one to us is about 30 minutes
away like 20 minutes away and I'm like
dude there's this gigantic pocket in the
Pasadena area that can be filled with
super chargers because there's so many
Tesla's over there but nah we're forced
to either go to Downey or to Glendale
and that's at the break my little Tesla
right okay like we can't even charge at
home and cuz I know that's probably what
some of you guys might question like why
can't you charge at home we don't have
the Tesla charger hooked up in our place
because right now we're renting and
since we're you know we're trying to get
a house like buy our own house we're
like oh we'll just install it once we
buy our own place so I had been charging
my car with the smallest voltage plug
like the regular plug and in order to
charge your cart that way just for like
about 15 percent of a charge it would
take 15 or 20 it would take over 24
hours to charge it's so slow because the
whole tip just so
so that's how I had been doing it but
then I tripped up the circuit breaker in
our place every time now that I try to
charge it and I think it might have been
an update like a Tesla plate
update somehow that it can--it ripped it
up because they did mention that now you
can charge an echo their protective
charges whatever the point is I can't
charge that home anymore and now I'm
griping about the superchargers but now
that's something that I actually have to
be mindful about and use so yeah I know
if you don't have a Tesla
I'm sorry I sound ridiculous and I hope
one day you get to have one because
they're really cool it's a really cool
part are you ever going to move back to
downing it's too busy for me and now
like that's why I want to move out of
where we're at we are now like I think I
really want to just live in a more like
quieter city more like actual suburbs
because this like Downey doesn't feel
like a suburb but feels like a major
city density of people here but you know
what the reason why I would want to live
here is because I really miss my hood I
miss my people and this the connection I
had with my peoples here and like I
don't know I don't I don't feel
connected to my culture anymore and it's
because I'm not surrounded by it because
in LA everyone lives in pockets and I'm
not in my Mexican pocket anymore
now I'm in an Asian pocket so like it's
I mean neighborhood the hood my your
headband your oh I didn't know there was
a difference it has a different
competition behind it well you know what
they say people that know the difference
came from the hood no okay so now that
we're in still with them tell me all
about it as I find parking alright so
this used to be an outdoor mall and fun
fact Back to the Future the first one
was filmed here and that was something
that was very known and it was often
talked about while I went to school
because people really love back to the
future and they were like you know that
Twin Pines mall whatever it was filmed
in stone wood it's so funny because this
is the mall that I came to my whole
childhood and for some reason it's
really hard for me to remember which
where each store is and like how to get
around in the mall which is ridiculous
because if you know Stonewood it's just
a straight shot like one because you
know how malls usually had like a lot of
turn like you have to do everyone's
either a triangle shape or like some
weird square shape thing but like this
is just like a rectangle is just like
one like hallway and like that's it like
that's you should know where every
single it's not a big wall but I think
cuz I was always very the opposite of
mindful aware I know we're gonna work
yes I was very unaware of my
surroundings constantly I would just not
really pay attention to where each store
was and then I'd end up coming here oh
because I first mentioned my high school
high school I went to was right over
there that's Downey high and then here's
the mall so it was a really cool thing
that we had a mall right across the
street from our high school so then we
used to meet up over here all the time
school and we would have our Jamba Juice
and I remember it Chipotle opened up in
the corner way over there when I was
still going to high school yeah it's
just so weird coming back because
everything looks older and I remember
when everything was brand new that's how
you know you've aged
[Music]
[Applause]
get lost here it's what we did you know
it's funny now that I'm seeing it
Longstreet shot
[Applause]
and Christina microphone oh sorry Bob
Mexican love to quit nacho cheese and a
hot cheetos and then
eat it out of the bag and I was like
cool they actually sell it here that's a
man down
[Applause]
I remember there was like one of those
casting call kind of feelings and
they're trying to like discover people
right and my mom I remember I was here
with my parents and then they went up
and the people like trying to recruit
whatever they were
very commercialism all this stuff and so
they had me like try out or whatever and
then I guess I passed that first round
but then they ended up having me walked
on the stage and like say my name and a
number
I remember my mom was like so happy
because she was like oh my god they're
gonna videotape I mean they're it's
gonna be broadcasted on TV and we were
in the living room waiting until I
walked up and I remember walking up and
thinking like oh my gosh I look like
that and that I think that was the first
time I ever criticized my school really
was like five years old I think really
yeah and then that's where
that went downhill my self-esteem went
downhill but anyway they're beating
yourself up you know what the first time
I started critiquing myself was when I
heard myself on an answering machine for
the first time it's like my voice sounds
like
remember with the kpop stuff he was like
deepening his voice because he didn't
like how you sound that's a very
kid-like first criticism thing to think
about but anyway like they ended up
wanting to cast me within my mom said
that they were asking for money which
looking back it sounds like
something should that's why I never
pursued modeling cuz I wanted to be a
model so bad
give me my bottle I mean I am your model
I'm gonna cool that I kind of turn right
now you're very uncomfortable when I
have to muscle for you you're awesome
oh my gosh this thing's remembered here
I remember I bought it
my best friend 15th birthday Poorna came
to me
and I ain't graved it like happy
birthday
like her birthday
I filled the entire photo album with I
was taking butter
and I printed all the pictures up and
then it gives her for a birthday and I'm
umbrellas sobbing my eyes and I can't
get much because I've known her since
kindergarten
it's like seeing her from kindergarten
until you see Anna like I had a speech I
could even get through it because I was
just bawling my eyes up and then from my
quinceanera I could shoot her birthday
was in September mine was in November
and actually he's got the exact same
date to September 29 November 29
two months later she ends up getting me
my engraved photo album as well which
when I get home I'll show you guys did
they still have it till this day just
remind me so you get
but that's where we got it from the
things remembered here and outings right
so look I know I'm not that crazy and
the whole me getting lost and stuff this
to the mall would branch out into little
kitchens like
[Applause]
like confused like wait where was that
one store was just here over there or
where am i again cuz every time I walk
into a store and I walk out I forget
what stretch or not walking it yeah it
happens to me when we're traveling then
I'm only walking out the subway I'm like
I have no idea where we just came from I
don't even got the stops are like all
the foreign languages get to you I got
you like shopping and going through like
[Applause]
you're circling around the clothes then
you're kind of like complaining a little
bit true you walk out you're likely
which I think it's pretty good yeah many
most people experience some form of that
because I thought I was pretty which
direction I was going it the small looks
old that looks old
yeah that looks old this was built in
like 1996 or something so we've finished
shopping we did a lot of shopping here
I'm shopping that we're on our way back
out and I told you it's easy to get lost
in this mall yeah no now we know we're
on the right direction because we now we
spot the food court which is wherever
you came in from obviously I love how we
literally got lost here and I'm like you
see this mall is easy to get lost as we
were walking in the wrong direction and
then we kept walking I was like wait is
it this way and then he was like no
we're not getting lost into one
direction
it's small but you could still get luck
see I was like I wasn't that dumb and
crazy when I was younger you did it too
we were lost
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that I've never seen that before
my gosh it's the best thing ever but she
I should have told her to open it from
the front I mean from the top I don't
know how she was gonna do it
pushy ended up marketing reaching room
though but that's not you do it it's
like punching it up in the back but your
Mickey shot you mixes every single tip
with dog you make these simply to be a
doggy in the cheese really s so against
what I think about when I think of chips
this might not shows even I don't like
my nacho soggy but you have to have this
dog
all right if they're soggy that means
you succeeded in coding every single tip
really yeah all right so and then from
the top of the bag I'm so freakin happy
right now this so high school
all right oh you got a lot
why don't we do this out in my
neighborhood
my childhood mom my husband just went
shopping you know it's funny so we
bought pillows that mini so that was a
first store that I went into but I'm
like I love how I immediately gravitates
in the Asian store dude I'm sorry
boy you're converting me over to this
now all right so we almost uploaded this
video but I forgot to show you guys I
held a loss telling about and things
remembered so I have it in this box here
with all my other family photos and here
it is being graved it with to our little
1:11 2904 which is when I turned 15 and
this is the three of us this is crystal
but when I was telling you about and I
like we ended up giving her an exact
same album and then we carved it and
then they also put Tiffany inside the
star but I just realized this year I
turned 30 so that means in November 29
this is gonna be 15 years old my photo
album can have a quinceanera that's
freaking crazy that just blows my mind I
can't believe it this is the photo that
Krystle and I took at that very same
mall cookie when we were eight or nine
years old stone wood was very very
connected to my childhood and I got the
proof right here
[Music]
[Music]